have you ever watched a dog that has
made you want to die while perusing the
internet one night I made a personal
discovery that would change my life
forever one that would torment my
nightmares and even make me think twice
about my job as a youtuber today I spent
four hours watching this what are you
going on about beerus you didn't do so
badly you know what
now some of you out there might be
wondering why why TNM why would you
knowingly subject yourself to this wet
part of a dub and in truth I don't know
but one thing is for sure I did it and
because of that today I am going to
review bang zoom entertainments English
dub for Dragon Ball super so the
wonderful people over a bang zoo
entertainment were tasked with crafting
an English dub for India and Southeast
Asia I didn't know anything about them
before jumping into this experience but
apparently they are a production studio
based out of California now when I
looked more into it these guys
apparently had a long list of anime I
liked under their belt like JoJo's
Bizarre Adventure
kill a kill and even Makoto Shinkai is 5
centimeters per second now I've never
seen any of these dub but knowing that
this dubbing company helped produce some
English dubs for these shows it gave me
hope hope that perhaps Funimation might
have competition in the English dubbing
Department needless to say I was wrong
this is easily one of the strangest
interpretations of super I have ever
seen now the first thing you might be
wondering is why do they sound so weird
why is the aspect ratio 3 by 4 why is
this happening all of these are
perfectly sane questions to tell you the
truth finding this diarrhea abortion of
a dub online was actually insanely
difficult because I don't live in Asia
there's really nowhere for me to watch
it the only place that seemed to have
the viewable files was a website called
toon anime India i-n and whoever was
recording and uploading these must have
been recording off an old box TV or
something I honestly didn't even know
Dragonball super could play on something
like that and that's not all on top of
this patch job of a collection there are
episodes missing to four to be exact I
couldn't find the full episodes 4 2 3 6
& 7 random I know but fret not ladies
and gentlemen because the website says
they are coming soon
so look forward to that and I'm sorry
for rambling on about this setup for
this but it was so strange I felt like I
needed to give context for this
Southeast Asian English dub found on an
Indian website recorded in three by four
aspect ratio so let's begin as soon as
episode 1 begins we quickly realize that
we are not in Kansas anymore
this is Lex Lang and he has an
interesting take on the character of
Goku
yes this is what we're dealing with here
and I promise it gets worse
bemused confused and a range of other
adjectives I ventured off to the
internet once again I figured that if
it's spat out this monstrosity it must
have some information on it to
apparently Lex Lang is a very
accomplished voice actor or at least I
would assume so given the amount of
credits I found under his name then I
saw it out of the corner of my eye he
was the voice actor for warGreymon from
digimon back in the 90s I had literally
no idea so that's pretty cool it doesn't
explain the piss-poor delivery but it's
pretty cool this is his first time
working for bang zoom entertainment as
far as I can discern but just so we know
who's doing the voice I'm gonna put
Lex's handsome face right there for his
performances yeah that's great oh yeah
another thing I forgot to mention about
the production of this show is that the
title cards the beginning and the ending
are all the Japanese versions they
didn't get the necessary materials
together to produce a title card of
their own English version like the
Funimation dubbed it which just adds to
the overall quality of this I think
moving on the first voice you'll hear is
the narrator who's a 40 year old that
sounds like a 20 year old trying to
sound like a 30 year old our world once
again balanced on the precipice of
destruction considering the English
Funimation dub and the Japanese original
took similar approaches and genuinely
confused why they chose this voice for
this role oh and remember Funimation's
majin buu well imagine they took the
most annoying aspects of that character
it's screaming I made an entire voice
based around that sounds insane right
why would they ever do that and that's
not where the strange voice choices end
Archie Fletcher's beerus sounds like
Pegasus from yugioh doing an impression
of beerus which is
interesting just kidding it's [ __ ] oh
really this is your best one or two of
the cast are actually pretty good
ignoring the terrible script of course
but we'll get to that with the majority
of the remaining being largely
inoffensive for the most part but only
if by an offensive you meant terrible
impressions of the Funimation cast get
out I am still training you may tell my
wife that I am NOT attending any absurd
celebrations it's honestly mind blowing
the sheer lack of effort and innovation
that went into this production what -
one or two characters every one of them
is in some way trying to copy the
Funimation dub and those that aren't
have such a lazy or embarrassing
interpretation of their characters
believe it or not I can actually see
certain aspects of this dub being better
than Funimation's in specific ways to
certain people I am NOT one of those
people and I never will be but there are
moments where arguments can be made that
they did a better job than Funimation
with regards accuracy to the original
you know - the terrible script and blah
blah blah did I just give bang zoom
entertainment a compliment oh that
actually hurt to say the voice of Bulmer
Wendy Swan is relatively harmless and I
would consider quite good this isn't her
first time filling the role of boom
either three decades ago in the 80s she
voiced boom before the Harmony Gold dub
of the original Dragon Ball
unfortunately she also directed the
voiceover for the Dragonball Evolution
videogame however the best performance
in the first arc comes from Michael
McConaughey who voiced King Kai the
second and final individual to come from
the original 1980s harmony dub and
personally a fan of Sean Simmons version
of King Kai however it's clear that
Makana he produces a much more faithful
interpretation of the Japanese character
too bad others didn't work out the same
way
where to begin whoa I know you just when
did I but wait if I'm not a god anymore
why don't I feel any weaker beerus
what's going on what's going on here
Lex Lang's Goku is the [ __ ] worst
there are so many instances where his
reactions are lines sound worse than a
crappy school play you didn't do so
badly you know what I mean come on that
cannot be the best take they had how bad
were these recording sessions what was
their house like it's really big
well that's the only way Hercule knows
how to be
on a serious note apparently shown
symbol even mentored him for the role
giving him advice on how to approach it
but these are truly terrible takes and
not just that the script is absolutely
dreadful the next clip I'm going to show
you broke me it literally broke me it's
easily the weirdest choice this dub ever
made for the first arc check it out
after seeing that I exclaimed
they gotta be [ __ ] with me because
that scene as was this entire production
is a joke aside from a few good
performances here and there this is
easily one of the most incompetent
English adaptations Dragon Ball has ever
had and I'm standing by that say what
you want about the big green dump but
this bang zoom entertainment [ __ ]
reaches over 250 million people across
the world which is [ __ ] insane to me
they do know the Internet is a thing
right they could just you know watch the
show and derive the script from the
subtitles fandubs of the series have
done a more straightforward and faithful
job there are scenes in this production
which would make you wonder if they've
ever seen a single episode of Dragon
Ball
see the fury of a Super Saiyan well then
here you go
I mean it's just embarrassing this is an
officially-licensed dub of Dragon Ball
super
I'm speechless I really don't think I've
ever seen a more obnoxious
interpretation of my favorite character
what you think I can't tell when you're
not going all-out so right through me
but this doesn't begin and end with Goku
beerus is almost as bad some of their
exchanges sound as though neither of
them care about what they're doing maybe
they knew how bad this was going and
just decided to have some fun I cringed
so frequently during my first viewing of
this dub that my face actually hurts
this dope literally hurt me physically
this is a dog that really no person
living in the West actually no scratch
that
no living person should ever be forced
to watch this it's line delivery is
strange irregular and wrong a lot of the
time it changes the motivations of
characters as well as the original
script and is despicably boring however
while I think this is a [ __ ] terrible
English dub that borders on insulting
the source material there is something
charming about it in an ironic way I
suppose what if you look past the fact
that this is the primary source for
hundreds of millions of people I rag
done a lot of different performances
during this video but make no mistake no
matter how good a voice actor is if the
script is bad it's next to impossible to
get anything good out of it and given
that the vast majority of the cast gave
neutral to terrible performances I'm
guessing the direction was terrible also
as of writing this video the dub has
been cancelled
but the resurrection F arc of this is
available in its entirety so who knows I
might subject myself to that someday too
for your amusement
as always commons of rings are very much
appreciated and i will see you guys next
week happy holidays and thank you so
much for watching
what